boa noite
eu sou maíra azevedo conhecida como te
ama e quando fui convidada para falar
aqui no texas sede x rio vermelho
eu imaginei que eu poderia falar sobre
várias coisas mas tem uma coisa que eu
não poderia deixar de falar que é a
minha luta diária para combater as
diversas formas de opressão
sou preta gorda nova china candomblés
pista mães solo periférica pobre eu só
aquilo que ninguém quer ver
e tudo isso me defini mas não me resume
e é justamente por isso que eu preciso
todos os dias todos os dias está
preparada para exercer a minha obrigação
de lutar por uma sociedade mais justa
igualitária e para muitas pessoas
o fato preocupa alguns espaços de poder
afinal de contas como disse renata é
hoje sei que estou em algum lugar que
são lugares chaves
eu produzo conhecimento eu sou alguém
que gera informação que já era conteúdo
e para muitas pessoas falar da minha
trajetória é tentar testar o discurso da
mary toque da cia que basta você se
dedicar que você consegue
na verdade eu sou a prova de quanto que
isso é falho
eu sou a prova de que é fundamental que
tem uma luta coletiva eu sou fruto do
conjunto eu sou fruto e resultado da
luta de várias pessoas que vieram antes
de mim para que hoje eu posso estar aqui
no palco do texas foi necessário que
várias pessoas fossem silenciados só que
pelo menos não tivesse nem a noção que
elas poderiam gritar e é por isso que
muitas vezes eu digo que eu sou a voz de
quem nunca pode falar ou de quem
historicamente é silenciado por isso que
todas as vezes que alguém questiona que
eu falo rápido demais o que eu falo alto
é porque a mulher preta tem ânsia de
falar porque a gente quase nunca é
ouvida a gente quase nunca é escutada e
aí eu costumo brincar
que dizem connect vai encarnar a gente
diz adeus como agente k cena e eu disse
que eu falei assim deus boa tarde tudo
bem eu vou encarnar e eu tô querendo ser
discriminada e aí deus vai dar pra mim
tem um pacote ótimo pra vocês que vai
nascer preta governo da china vai morar
em plataforma vai criar seu filho
sozinha e olha vai pegar mirante de
periperi itaigara de vez em quando é bom
rever o motivo
e eu falei poxa vou tentar caprichar
mais ainda quando cheguei aqui nasce com
a língua presa e ainda falam rápido pois
é mas é discriminada onde eu tenho que
lutar todos os dias contra isso não vai
impedir que eu sigo em frente
e cada vez que eu sigo em frente ocupa
um espaço eu compreendo
eu compreendo que eu tenho a obrigação
de chamar outras pessoas para meu lado
porque essa luta é coletiva e tecla
aprendi com tudo isso eu comecei a
aprender que humor que eu tenho que é
peculiar poderia ser uma grande
ferramenta de transformação é possível
ouvir e refletir e aí que eu criei o dia
mar com a língua solta aqui pra quem não
entendeu porque minha língua presa e
ficar com a língua solta uma tarefa
talvez mais difícil até porque é
combater diversas formas de opressão em
uma sociedade racista machista sexista
homofóbica
a meritocracia não existe ea gente não
pode se enganar com isso ou então tentar
reduzir as dores de outras pessoas
simplesmente chamar de vitimismo ou de
mimi
na verdade eu até comecei a dizer que a
mim me sim até porque me é um ano matou
pé ea simplista que quer reproduzir o
choro não é isso
mimi está falando só com nosso choro não
é à toa
a gente chora porque a cada 23 segundos
uma mulher está sendo espancada
violentada a gente chora porque a cada
17 segundos um jovem negro assassinado
a gente chora porque uma menina negra de
candomblé quando sai por aí recebe
pedradas pela cara
então amy inimigo que a gente está
chorando chorando para assegurar nossas
vidas
a gente não quer mais ficar lá e é isso
que incomoda porque eu não posso mais
admitir que outra pessoa diga qual é o
tamanho da minha dor a dor que eu sinto
só eu sei e eu não posso aceitar que
outra pessoa já dei por mim um homem
branco não vai saber o quanto dói ser
uma mulher negra não vai saber e falar
sobre isso é de fato fundamental para a
gente poder compreender que existem
diferenças em outra coisa não é normal
não é natural
viver em locais que não têm diversidade
a diversidade é lucrativa ela forma e
ela é duca é importante que você veja
diferente a diferente para você se
reconhecer
é a partir daí que você forma sua
identidade
é importante que tem um homem branco
para saber com a sua mulher preta e
muitas vezes a gente não entende que
essa formatação mas a padronização é na
verdade o fruto da determinação quando
eu falo que eu sou a primeira mulher
negra do brasil a ter um stand up eu
vivo nesse espaço também a solidão da
mulher negra que não se reduz à questão
afetiva e reduz na questão empresarial
na questão profissional quando cheguei
determinados espaços ea o pra mim é
normal é ninguém se assustar que não
tenha negros e negras em espaços de
poder
isso que é normal anormal é a gente
ainda conseguia aceitar que discriminem
uma criança que não completou nem dois
anos porque o racismo é extremamente
democrático o racismo atinge a todos ea
todas ea gente quer ficar vivendo nesse
ledo engano e se leve em gum no que o
problema é social não é razão e não é
verdade
cada vez mais a gente sabe que milhares
de pessoas pretas e ricas também são
discriminadas o racismo negam nossa
humanidade como abordou fobia também só
quem é gordo só que é gorda sabe o quão
doloroso é adentrar em um espaço
esse olhar tudo como se fosse uma
aberração
só uma mulher gorda sabe o quanto é ruim
ela ser regularizada quando as pessoas
olham bela e diz
mas você é tão linda porque você não
emagrece ea gente acha que isso é uma
bobagem o argumento de muitas pessoas a
dizer eu estou preocupada com sua saúde
mas é importante que você se preocupar
com sua vida e deixar outra pessoa me
cuidar porque aquela pessoa está feliz
então como uma às vezes quem está no
tacho um ótimo né ea pessoa também não é
da conta de ninguém né
e eu falo essas coisas todas muita gente
fala assim
mas parece que você só quer falar sobre
isso ou então tem a frase clássica
o próprio negro se discrimina a própria
mulher se deprecia ou então o próprio
gordo faz faz brincadeira coisas a gente
é educado para ser machista
a gente é educado para ser racista a
gente educada para ser gordo fóbico e
muitas vezes reproduzir essas frases
preconceituosas é talvez uma forma
indevida de assegurar a existência o
projeto gaiato a preta gaiata que chegue
fazem que provoca o entretenimento e se
é aceito muito bem mas o negro que vai
lá e toca na ferida que fala
sabendo que vai falar isso incomoda eu
aprendi que eu sei que é por isso que
muitas vezes chegam em alguns espaços e
eu incomodo porque eu digo todos os dias
eu fui educada e muito bem educada pra
competir de igual pra igual para um
homem branco
o que me falta a oportunidade é uma
oportunidade que tira a gente do espaço
impede que a gente chega em outro e quem
faz isso são as diversas formas de
preconceito quando alguém acha que uma
mulher não tem condições de ser uma
liderança porque ela tem um jeito
maternal demais e começam a duvidar da
nossa capacidade
apenas pela questão do nosso gênero isso
inclusive é alguém que não consegue
acompanhar as estatísticas porque a oit
organização internacional do trabalho
atestou que empresas que são chefiadas
por mulheres
lucram muito mais mas o machismo pede
isso aí te também atesta em alguns
estudos que empresas que têm a
diversidade diversidade não é só a
palavra de efeito a diversidade é algo
real
essas empresas costumam também tem um
lucro muito maior
o que será que impede já que organismos
internacionais asseguram que é onde a
gente consegue combater o preconceito a
gente consegue fazer a mudança por que
será que a gente não consegue colocar
isso na prática porque a gente tem muita
dificuldade de assumir que muitas vezes
o preconceito mostrando a gente mal o
preconceito é primo do diabo um ano
detalhes
às vezes é a piada é o olhar jocoso é
aquela forma depreciativa de se dirigir
ou então definir alguém é assim que faz
e eu poderia chegar aqui e falar de
milhares de outras coisas mas enquanto
muita gente tem que esconder o racismo o
machismo a homofobia
cada vez mais gente tem que falar tem
gente que fala que agora está na moda
mas não é que está na moda é porque
agora a gente resolveu falar dessas
coisas porque assim talvez talvez a
gente comece a se constrange porque deve
ser muito doloroso assume que o brasil é
o primeiro país do mundo na morte
o assassinato de homens gays e travestis
ea gente acha que essa morte apenas a
morte da bala a morte da piada à morte
daqui para ridicularizar ridiculariza a
pessoa
essa morte a gente não quer contar a
morte que é de khat com ledsham a
criança negra de macaca e que talvez
isso afete a vida dessa menina para
sempre a gente não fala sobre isso e
outra coisa racismo não é brincadeira
racismo na opinião racismo é crime e tem
que aprender a chamar as coisas pelos
nomes corretos homofobia não é opinião
tem muita gente que fala eu não aceito o
casamento gay mas foi você que foi
pedido em casamento quem tem que aceitar
ou não é que recebeu o convite não é que
sua conta mas as pessoas querem o tempo
todo
ronaldo o direito da outra pessoa
opinião você guarda opinião eu sempre
digo que a opinião é opinião é
extremamente particular é igual a você
tem nem sempre você precisa dar ea gente
precisa cumprir aquilo que ela entendeu
agora nem sempre você precisar ou então
se for dado um jeitinho é menos dolorosa
ea gente não pode confundir as coisas
chega de botar pelo ídolo que tem nome
racismo é crime a homofobia ainda não
foi criminalizada mais mata também ea
gente precisa inclusive lutar para que
seja dessa forma porque chega italy
todos os dias vendo pessoas sendo
assassinadas por conta da sua orientação
por conta da sua condição porque ninguém
escolhe
ninguém escolhe eu não nasci pedindo
para ser discriminada todos os dias pra
mim é doloroso demais quando eu tenho
que abrir a porta de minha casa respirar
fundo e não poder só viver eu tenho que
viver e combater todos os dias às
diversas formas de opressão mesmo eu não
estou preparada porque pra mim viver é o
maior desafio afinal de contas eu tenho
a obrigação de todos os dias
driblar as mais diversas perversas
estatísticas muito obrigado
[Aplausos]